We've stopped up here at one of the viewpoints on Mt. Fuji...
...and we get this incredible view of some of the other Japanese mountains.
The peak of Mt. Fuji doesn't seem that high when you're up here at the viewpoint,...
...but it's actually almost 4,000 meters above sea level.
We've made it here to Lake Ashi,...
...we're gonna hop on the boat and sail around.
So we're out here on Lake Ashi...
...and not only is it breathtaking and known for its hot springs,...
...but most importantly, it's known for the incredible views of Mt. Fuji.
Got my ticket, gonna head up the Hakone Ropeway.
So the ropeway has brought us up here to the top of Komagatake...
...and the views are breathtaking.
You have Mt. Fuji, you have Lake Ashi...
...and then in the distance, the Pacific Ocean.
I'm in love.